ce serait vous mentir de vous dire que
tout va bien je suis totalement sous le
choc
mais avant ça déjà bonjour tout le monde
évidemment bienvenue dans ce petit
rendez vous alors pas du mercredi cette
fois ci mais du jeudi 1 je ne pouvais
pas hier vous produire vous sortir la
vidéo
donc voilà c'est aujourd'hui tout
d'abord sachez que ce n'est pas la fin
ce n'est pas parce que l'eau qui est
terminée entre guillemets qu'on ne va
plus en parler bien au contraire il y
encore énormément de choses à traiter
c'est tout a explosé là je peux vous
assurer que le mc hué reparti de plus
belle la pour de nombreuses années
là les révélations c'est de la pure
dinguerie franchement là je suis refaite
j'ai refait donc évidemment n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner à la chaîne pour ne
louper aucune des prochaines vidéos
parce que là il va y en avoir clairement
ce n'est pas la fin là il y a plein de
choses à faire et à dire
et en plus de ça il ya une grosse vidéo
qui va arriver dans les prochains jours
en compagnie de mon var ayant préféré
bref voilà rentrons dans le vif du sujet
kang est annoncée kang et la cc c'est
juste fou en fait on en a parlé
tellement ces dernières semaines dès
l'épisode 2 et tout ça fait vraiment
bizarre
de le voir là là qu'il ait annoncé ses
sa annonce clairement du lourd tout
d'abord concentrons nous sur le
personnage c'est dans ces moments que
l'on peut voir l'intelligence de ceux
qui dirigent le marvel cinématiques et
du haut niveau car effectivement toute
la saga s'inspire des comics de
plusieurs histoires de buddh scénario
etc et beaucoup de choses sont réadapter
et simplifié mais tout en respectant des
éléments établis par les comics à la
base c'est le cas ici avec le nom de pau
remains soit celui qu'il demeure une
entité dont nous avions déjà parlé et
qui est à l'origine de tout ce qui
concerne le temps le tva et caetera et
qui a créé les time keepers pour
contrôler la tva et protéger le flux
temporel et du coup kang est bel et bien
celui qui demeure il a établi le tva il
sait tout il a vécu des millions de vie
etc et il a créé le concept de time
keepers donc tout le symbolisme est très
fort d'ailleurs je l'appelle kong
mais certains vont me titille et là
dessus nous sommes plus face à une
représentation de him or tus de son vrai
nom nathaniel richard's immo retenu cet
invariant de gangs pour être plus
concret personne ne le connaît vraiment
comme dans la série du coup personne ne
sait que c'est lui qui dirige tout il
est le souverain des limbes dans l'image
la personne que l'on a en face de nous
vit à l'extérieur de tout un lieu hors
de l'espace et du temps comme les limbes
en quelque sorte on retrouve les mêmes
vêtements que dans les comics ce n'est
pas un conte véritablement maléfique
comme on pourrait le penser à cause de
son variant conquérant bref nous sommes
face à une représentation du maure tus
d'ailleurs tim hortons est lié à la tva
et à la fin de son existence et marié
arts à vonnas et ont même un enfant
alors je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils iront
jusqu à l'enfant mais l'idée que ravaux
naim hortus tombe amoureux à l'avenir
notamment dans la saison 2 ce n'est pas
une idée folle et cela pourrait
clairement arrivé nous en avons déjà
beaucoup parler dans les précédentes
sauf que là vous allez me dire bah oui
mais il mord tus
il est mort à la fin d'épisode si cela
il a été tué par sylvie et bien c'est
plus compliqué que ça et ça va nous
donner l'occasion de faire de belles
théories sur le mc eu comme expliqué à
loki et sylvie les variants de gangs ont
découvert qu'il existe d'autres univers
d'autres mondes qu'il se contacter airs
qu'ils partageaient savoirs et
connaissances sauf qu'évidemment il
existait des variants hostile qui
voulait conquérir les autres monde et
cela a donné la guerre multi vercel une
guerre qui a été stoppée par him or tu
ce grâce à l'utilisation d'alli lot et
qui lui a permis d'isoler le flux
temporel
sauf que en tuant him or tous à la fin
des temps sylvie à déclencher une
nouvelle guerre multi vers celle qui
ouvre la porte à tous les autres gangs
mais au final qui termine la guerre
multi vercel et bien c'est tim hortons
et là je vous avoue que c'est un gros
débat que je vais avoir avec vous c'est
une théorie que j'ai commencé à
travailler de mon côté un mais
de l'ordre menées le chaos et du chaos
naît l'ordre la dictature de la tva
créer le chaos a mené par nos deux lots
qui loki qui symbolise le chaos
de part son imprévisibilité sa malice
ses trahisons donc loki tui morte us le
chaos
tu l'ordre sauf que du chaos ban et
l'ordre et en tuant team hortus une
nouvelle guerre un nouveau chaos se
présente et dans ce chaos se dégage immo
russe qui va instaurer l'ordre
nos sommes sur une boucle c'est pourquoi
nous reverrons est morte us il ne dit
pas que c'est invariant que sylvie va
rencontrer du style un nouveau gang qui
va contrôler le tva et le flux temporel
non il dit bien je te reverrai bientôt
nous le voyons d'ailleurs quand il a
terminé la guerre multi vercel entouré
d'un cercle symbolisant le flux temporel
toujours cette idée de boucles et pour
continuer surtout ce côté symbole bon je
pense et garder cette théorie pour le
trois théories de fins de séries mais
bon la mise en scène de l'épisode est
très minutieuse est calculé sylvie est
assise à gauche
habillés en noir et l'eau qui est assis
à droite avec sa chemise blanche
nous sommes face à la fameuse théorie du
yin yang est bien dans le yin yang
il n'y a pas que la couleur noir et
blanc le côté noir symbolise aussi la
féminité donc sylvie et le blanc la
masculinité donc loki et c'est un
symbole très fort et très puissant carlo
qui est sylvie se ressemblent
terriblement ils sont des lots qui met
sont à la fois très différents et c'est
le principe de base du yin yang deux
entités qui s'opposent et qui à la fois
se complètent parfaitement et immo russe
le sait très bien et symbolise l'antre 2
en quelque sorte
il met son patin temporel au milieu de
la table de façon très minutieuse et
il attend il attend de voir quelles
extrémités va prendre le dessus sur
l'autre
évidemment look et sylvie se combattent
l'opposition est montré puissant brasse
c'est la complémentarité et sylvie trahi
finalement loki et s'empare du pad
temporel une extrémité a pris le dessus
sur l'autre et c'est là que je me pose
question est ce que ea morte us ne
sait-il vraiment pas ce qu'il va se
passer si nous sommes sur une thématique
de boucles et qu'il va revenir du coup
après la guerre multi vercel est-ce que
du coup ce n'est pas la première fois
puis qu'il y a eu tout ce cheminement et
cette conversation avec les deux lots
qui tout ça ce serait déjà passé
plusieurs fois
sauf que le résultat était toujours le
même jusqu'à maintenant l'eau qui
trahissaient sylvie à chaque fois c'est
une idée ce serait pour quoi est morte
us trash talk l'eau qui durant la
conversation comme quoi c'est quelqu'un
qui a fait des choses horribles qu'on ne
peut pas se fier à lui et caetera et
donc qui galvanise sylvie mais bon c'est
une idée comme ça c'est une simple
théorie qui provient de ma tête mais
cela puis une autre incompréhension
c'est pourquoi l'eau qui atterrit dans
un autre univers
un autre monde nous sommes face à une
manipulation au niveau du montage car
nous voyons le mobile us et hunter
bishop tine que nous connaissons puis
quand l'eau qui va leur parler
la mise en scène de sa marche dans la
bibliothèque est très importante car
elle traduit l'idée d'un lot qui
traversant les univers compilé comme
expliqué paris morte us et atterri dans
un autre univers où mobius ne le connaît
pas ou enter by fifteen ne le connais
pas et haut la statue du véritable gang
le conquérant comme démontré par sa
tenue la véritable menace est présente
et du coup l'incompréhension c'est
comment sylvie a pu balancer l'eau qui
dans un autre monde
immo russe possède un pad spécial c'est
sûr mais de là à ce que sylvie envoie
l'eau qui dans un autre monde
je sais pas je trouve ça bizarre j'ai
comme l'impression que c'est une
manipulation dit morte us sachant que
loki
ce nage principal notre héros entre
guillemets c'est lui l'élément clé de
l'histoire le symbole du changement et
de l'avenir donc il n'est pas là bas par
hasard et donc cela voudrait dire qu'il
existerait un tva par monde par univers
également j'aimerais maintenant
terminées sur deux éléments i ly a
clairement une sorte de stigmatisation
des lots qui dans la série on en parlait
d'ailleurs dans les précédentes vidéos
l'épisode 5 nous a montré que dans la
zone nul la zone où tu te fais brouillé
il y avait beaucoup de loki mais en même
temps ce n'est pas une zone réservée aux
lots qui puisque mobius y est envoyé
aussi et bien je dirais que c'est parce
que him or tu cherches un lot qui comme
successeur et tous les autres à part
l'eau qui est sylvie du coup aurait
échoué ils ont fait le personne n'avait
jamais réussi à vaincre alliotte à part
du coup sylvie et l'eau qui y meurent
tous possèdent un réel intérêt envers
loki mais c'est la grande question c'est
de savoir qu'est ce qu'il attend
justement de loki et sylvie pourquoi il
veut un lot qui en tant que successeur
et là je vous avoue qu'il peut y avoir
ni les une théorie et ça va être un
plaisir d'explorer tout ça et enfin je
voulais terminer aussi sur une petite
vulgarisation vous donner un petit ips
pour ceux qui auraient du mal à
conceptualiser tout le délire de monts
deux branches de réalité de machin de un
truc et bien essayé de voir ça comme une
forêt un arbre symbolise un univers un
monde est évidemment un arbre est
composé de branches des branches qui
sont irrégulières et propre à chaque
arbre donc ce qui fait que chaque arbre
est unique en quelque sorte
eh bien ces branches se sont les
réalités les nexus quand l'eau qui s'est
échappé avec le tc raked dans endgame il
a créé une nouvelle branche de l'arbre
une nouvelle réalité de son univers et
le tva se chargent de taille et l'arbre
pour pas que ça parte trop dans tous les
sens bref il ya tellement de mystère à
traiter d'éléments à théoriser tous et
c'est trop bien comptez sur moi pour
être là et vous proposer de belles
théories de belles analyses etc
l'introduction de comptes dans le mc n
est pas du tout anodine cela me rappelle
clairement l'introduction de tano ce qui
a été fait sur plusieurs années puisque
nous reverrons kangs dans la saison 2
nous reverrons kong d'entente man 3 il y
a le lien avec doctor strange 2 qui va
parler du multivers et où il ya une
chance que l'eau qu'ils soient dans le
film lui aussi donc évidemment un lien
avec kong sans oublier l'énorme rumeurs
des trois spider man qui trotte depuis
un moment là l'idée de
du multivers cd monde qui vont s'ouvrir
aux autres et c'est cela appuie
clairement l'idée que les trois spider
man pourrait se réunir grâce du coup à
la série law qu'ils aient aux actes de
kong entre guillemets bref on est
reparti là pour de belles années et ça
fait trop plaisir à là je suis vraiment
trop hype et je suis trop motivés sachez
en tout cas que tout ce que je vous dis
tout ce que je vous raconte cela
provient de ma tête c'est ma vision
personnelle des choses de l'épisode et
c'est à vous de me dire vos perceptions
il peut exister une infinité de
possibilités une infinité de deux
visions comme évidemment une infinité de
gangs dans la petite métaphore
bon je suis désolé ma came à couper ça
fait trop longtemps que je filme
apparemment un gros trois théories dédié
à la série law qui arrive dans les
prochains jours en compagnie de mon
variant préférées je vous attends pour
ce rendez vous mythique
n'oubliez pas également le petit bout ce
bleu à vous abonner et puis écouté que
le lionheart soit avec vous c'était
dargaud rock cha où tout le monde
[Musique]